you
what I'd like to say is I've done a few
of these before I like them to be very
interactive what I would say ask any
question you want I never liked to have
any question off bounds I know I'm being
in a taped so I some some questions I
may be able to answer a bit more frankly
than others i will do my best to be as
Frank as possible sometimes maybe if it
was just a private I could be very frank
but I encourage you to ask any question
what you'd like you won't offend me
that's what we're here to have a
discussion so what's ever on your mind
please feel free to ask me what I'd like
to do is go through just I have some a
few slides that I'd like to take maybe
five minutes and walk through just to
give you if you aren't familiar maybe
give you an idea of who we are what we
do what are some of the issues we face
and then I have a last slide on a couple
of issues matters that I thought would
be of interest if our questioning takes
us in other directions that's great
because this is not about me it's about
you and so the things that I have are
some of the issues that we're facing as
an industry and also some of the
experiences that I've had around manning
Jeannie managing people and managing a
career and some things that I think are
useful for you to know is you begin that
track and so quickly I just like to walk
through a few slides that go through
where we operate so it gives you an idea
of where we're located where we might
have operations where we're building
projects around the world and so we're
very diverse I should say we're very
diverse geographically we're not as
diverse if you look at our people in our
organization we're very we look a lot
like me if i can say that like and we're
trying to change that and but you can
see we're probably a little under
underrepresented in africa which has
been in it been an issue that we're
trying to correct as we go forward we
have a couple of very large projects
that were looking at in Africa but also
in South America also but we but the key
about one of the keys about our business
is and as we talk maybe it
at the end about some of the issues we
are facing we can't choose where we go
to operate we have to go where the
resources are and a lot of the easy
resources have been found and a lot of
those that are in more stable countries
are already in operation and some of the
more prospective areas are places like
Africa where governments are not as
stable operating environments and
physical regimes are not quite the same
and legal institutions are not as strong
and so those are some of the issues that
we're facing as an organization if you
look at what we do this just kind of
gives you an idea of the various areas
we're at and where we are in those
markets size-wise I'll have another
slide shortly that will show profits
that will give you an idea where our
profitability is spread across those
markets some of you might see have seen
that many companies will say well we
have to be number one or two in a
marketer we don't want to be in it the
way we look at it is we search for the
best opportunities we do put put
opportunities or commodities through a
review there are certain commodities
that we prefer not to be in because we
don't see the industry dynamics as being
that favorable I'll say zinc may be one
of those where it's more plentiful you
don't find large resources we are mantra
and our strategy is very large low-cost
long life so we're looking at things
that will last for a minimum of 20 years
hopefully 50 60 70 80 years which is a
very long time for a mine and that will
produce when you look at its production
rates compared to other minds are very
large mines we have an in copper we have
interests in some of the you know the
top if you look across I think where we
have interest in three of the top ten
nine modules in the world the one thing
I was going to say I'm just going to go
back as we come back there's also a
reason I put this picture on the slide
and I'll come back to it hopefully a
little bit later but I just want you to
remember that and I'll plant a seed
one of the things that really that we're
very proud of and and I truly believe it
is that we work very hard on being
environmentally responsive sustainable
development which I include environment
health and safety both of communities
but also our workers but also how we
deal with governments and communities
but when you look at that picture we
will never be seen as a green company
will we no matter what we do we can be
the best in our industry but we will
never be seen as somebody that's a
standout because we have an impact
there's there you know and in some areas
this is not a mind that we will clean up
and we'll be gone once we're done but
somewhere some types of mining that we
do once we're done you wouldn't know
we've been there but this won't be one
of them if you look at where we sell and
what we sell as of late by destination
we do sell around the world but you can
see how Asia is that is really beginning
to dominate our industry if you looked
at China five years ago 66 years ago
instead of being twenty-five percent of
our our revenue it would have been a
less than ten percent so that gives you
an idea of how it's been growing if you
look at what we sell you know pretty
diverse but we have been a bit more
weighted towards iron ore and aluminium
iron ore to to partly because its price
has been so high so it's kind of skewing
that a little bit I put this up just
just to give you you can see where we
make money but certain commodities or
come in and out of favour if i can say
it that way from a pricing perspective
so these things go up and down over time
but but what i would point out is if you
look at 2008 that was a record year for
us and look at the first half of 2010
which is that last bar there we made
almost in the first half of this year as
we almost made as much as we made in
tooth
and nine and pricing for most of our
commodities have gotten better in the
second half than they were in the first
half I mean if you just look at
consensus for what we'll do well this
will be a record year for us and we're
still in a very uncertain economy
particularly in the US as I travel
around the world different economies you
get different fields for how people feel
what's going on and what the future is
like in the u.s. it's still very
uncertain people are unwilling to really
kind of start investing we're investing
we haven't announced it to the market
yet so I can't get into a lot of detail
yet but but what I would say is come
februari look and see what we start well
I think we're going to start saying
talking about it in November our
investment pipeline for the next five
years is more than we've ever spent
before very high levels of investment
and I'll talk about maybe a couple of
those well it did start Club end of the
year though so didn't really hit tell
about October we were going gangbusters
and literally our iron ore group was
just flat-out doing everything it could
to produce more iron ore and I'm not
kidding you over a weekend in october
the ship's disappeared at the ports in
australia they just left orders just
dried up things just fell apart so there
were wobbles but for for it really
didn't hit till the end of 08 and then
but but when you look where this is
going to be a record year were demand on
what we need to do from to build new
supply is just enormous for us we cannot
invest we actually are having trouble
getting our our people and businesses to
spend capital fast enough and when I
tell people that that are in other
businesses they just kind of look at me
well we won't approve capital let alone
we can't get them to move fast enough
coming out of the global financial
crisis where we had to take some very
significant steps because
while we had a record year that year we
were also under very heavy heavy debt
after by making the Alcan acquisition if
you're familiar with her company maybe
which was an all-cash deal the markets
fell apart we had in hindsight had
bought something that was a very big
acquisition acquisition near the top of
the market and we couldn't turn out that
debt and some of those things as a
result of that we were main competitor
was coming after us trying to bias and
so we were kind of a stuck in a position
and then suddenly the markets fell apart
and we had a huge amount of debt i would
say that in june of last year so almost
18 months ago we had 40 billion dollars
a dead at the end of this year and if
you look at what the analysts are saying
we'll have about somewhere around five
billion dollars in debt and they're
about right so it just gives you an idea
how the world for us has changed in in
18 months just quickly I mean if you
look at what's happening in the world
and we've been caught off to some degree
in different areas as surprised as
everybody else as the Asian economies
are taking off they're going through
that in that period of growth that is
very material intensive that you saw
Japan go through say in the 50s and the
60s the US and European economies went
went through that much much before then
but just just to give you an idea let's
say copper over the next 20 years we
expect more copper to be used in the
world that has been used in the last 70
years and when we look at what we we
have to be producing twice as much
copper in 20 years as we are today and
if you we produce as a world about in
round terms i'll use about 15 million
tons of copper a year so we're going to
have to produce somewhere around 30
million tons of copper in 20 years we're
developing one of the largest minds in
Mongolia right now that will produce a
little less than a half a million tons
of copper so to meet the demand going
forward in 21 years we're going to have
to produce 30 of those operations over
the next 20 years about and it's costing
us about 5 billion dollars to develop
that one operation that just gives you a
little bit of a view on the scale that
our industry is facing as we move
forward and just quickly the only reason
I really put this up is as you see
what's happening in China as well as
India is starting to to follow it it's a
little bit slower it's not as commanding
control as China is so it's not
happening quite as quickly and smoothly
when I say smoothly at such a consistent
rapid pace year-on-year it's but but I
think in India as I visit there more and
more my view is the genies out of the
bottle the people that the up and coming
generation in India wants and this is
happening around the world they want
everything that you have and that genies
out of the bottle and it's coming so you
happy for questions that was just a
brief introduction that I wanted to give
a little bit about a company what's
happening I think you may have done some
reading there have been some case
studies that have been done there are
things around some of the issues that we
face it's a company I think somebody
mentioned to me that I might get some
questions on the bribery issues that we
faced in China and our four people that
were arrested and subsequently found
guilty and sentenced to jail there are
out can acquisition and some of the
dynamics around that and what it how it
kind of put the company in a difficult
position I'm happy to answer or discuss
any of those like I said nothing off off
limits yes not any of those actually
when you say we need more to have a good
South America there are T like my keys
in there despite the riskiness of
instability like I know Guinea has very
large box i deposited yeah there's
definitely competing company in there
you know they had kool-aid last year so
are you just adjusting your company's
profiler is willing to got more risk now
um yeah we where we're realizing that we
have been somewhat in some instances
conservative when it comes around moving
into more risky locations so we had an
opportunity and we actually had an
interest in Colombia in a Nicole
operation which has turned out to be a
very successful operation over time we
sold out of that in the mid-90s mainly
due to risks around operating inch
Columbia and looking back we can say we
did that way too early if you go back 30
years ago now now two of the biggest
operations and most profitable
operations that really drove our company
were in Africa there's a copper copper
operation in South Africa and uranium
operation in Namibia and so we've we've
worked in less secure places or you know
let's develop places but sometimes we've
been a little reluctant to be as
aggressive as I think we should be in
those areas and we're realizing we do
need to change that Guinea we have a
massive iron or iron ore opportunity
there and we're having one of the issues
that we're facing is that that first
group of my name is issues is the view
that guinea sees around the strategic
nature of that resource because it is so
big and governments wanting a bigger
piece of the pie that's probably about a
12 10 to 12 billion dollar development
massive impact on the country and so you
see the struggles that we're facing and
trying to develop it but what the
government wants as well we also have to
go where where the resources are as I
said earlier so wherever we have
find resources and Africa is one of the
untapped potentials for very large
resources including if you want to be in
copper over time one of the biggest is
the copper belton in Africa which
includes Zambia and the DRC and so we're
going to have to be there over time if
we're going to be in these commodities
and so we're going to have to adapt one
of the things is be much better about
government relations than we are today
yeah I think copper is one that has
probably the best set of fundamentals
because it's growing so quickly it's
it's it's plentiful but not plentiful in
high concentrations you can find it at
what grades that we would say about
point five point four which are very
hard to mine profitably a 1-percent
copper mine used to be a low grade
copper mine nowadays it's if you find a
one-percent copper mine that that is a
superb fine they're also getting deeper
so if you look at underground mining for
copper today it's about twenty-five
percent of copper is produced from
underground we figured by about twenty
twenty it will be about double that
amount so it's getting deeper and the
deeper harder to find more complex to
develop much more expensive there's the
really big block caving copper upper
opportunities probably right today
pranaam only be developed by three maybe
four companies that will evolve over
time but right now met coal so used in
iron may used in still making not as
plentiful and where it is being found
now is in more difficult locations like
Mozambique to develop I think it has
very strong fundamentals
iron ore mainly because usually it's
it's such a logistics challenge to get
when you when you mine iron ore it's not
about mining it's all about logistics we
were talking about that is if our iron
ore mines in Australia which are some of
the biggest in the world we own about
1,500 kilometers of a private rail
system that we run ourselves we run it
through an automated operation center
that's based in Perth which is about
probably 2,000 1,500 2,000 kilometres
away from where the mines are it's a
combination of about twenty mines and
they have to mine it and train it all to
the same locations and blend it into a
common common final product that then is
loaded onto ships and so when you think
about taking 20 different operations and
some are up and some are down and some
have problems maybe equipment breaks or
whatever and managing that logistics
chain to make sure that you're blending
to a certain speck of a final product is
you know something you have helped us
with is is quite an undertaking i I'm
sorry I think there was a the prices are
I'm gonna go yes for the suppliers get
em it means for the consumers yes good
for us so um what's the competitive
environment like competing in China with
Chinese firms and you think that
arrest imprisonment of your employees
was in any way related to that it's it's
very it's very difficult we don't
believe we can operate in China at least
as the majority owner so we are looking
to partner with Chinese they very much
see it as a strategic resources you've
seen this with the debate that China has
recently got gotten into over some of
the the sea issues or two and they've
been using rare Ursa's it appears at
least let's say as kind of a part of a
tool against Japan in this debate China
wants to own its resources and and
that's one of the issues when you when
you look at what China faces they
realize what they have to they don't
have the ability to meet their own
internal needs through their own
commodities in country so you will see
them going out more and more in trying
to buy commodities run operations in
other countries and they've been doing
that very aggressively in Africa and
South America successful sometimes not
so successful in other way sometimes
they haven't been haven't worked really
well with in dealing with community and
community issues we think we can put we
think we need to partner with Chinese
and that's why we've been working with
Janelle co because they will be doing
that and they have cheap financing which
could be a big boom to us but also we
have technology and capabilities that
they would like to have we have
reputation and around the way we operate
and our excellence that that could be
beneficial that gets us access to
certain commodities or deposits I should
say that they might not be able to get
so we think that that can be a win-win
we think we we just like we've been
working on negotiation agreement within
China to try and work with them to
identify deposits in China but we also
recognize we're not going to be the
majority owner we may be able to operate
because for a period they will want to
gain their own operational expertise
over time and replace us we do recognize
that
the arrests hard to say I would but I
think the evidence would say they were
probably somewhat connected yes and but
looking back and having done our own
investigation we now know that this was
something that was going on for some
period of time as well our people were
taking bribes it was completely outside
of our systems it was cash in garages
and things like that but they were doing
it and they were guilty of what they
were what they were found guilty of
doing as well and that that hurt us it
hurt us with other governments around
the world but it hurt us in China and
after we bought out can and got
ourselves into a very heavy position and
weren't able to do things like share
issuances or terming out that debt and
some of the things we might have been
able to do before the global financial
crisis hit as I said our competitor came
after us in a bid and so we kind of had
our hands tied as to what some of the
things we could do externally we
couldn't issue stock to help pay down
some of the debt which may have been an
option we were considering because we
couldn't issue stock and put a price on
our stock that then they could say well
we'll buy at that price so we found
ourselves in a very difficult position
after the whole world fell apart then
and we were still heavy with that debt
we there weren't a lot of options for us
to try and bolster the finances of the
company and we entered into an agreement
I don't know how many of you are
familiar we entered into an agreement
with Chanel Co to make a significant
investment of almost 20 billion dollars
into our company and at the time there
weren't many other options the world the
financial markets were closed we
couldn't borrow money we couldn't issue
stock our stock price went down eighty
percent you probably didn't want an
issue stock yeah it was a scary time
my whole my whole net worth is tied to
the rio tinto share it was a very it was
a very scary time for a lot of people
within six months things started really
changing we could we could do other
things and it was apparent that the deal
that we had negotiated at that time
which was the best we could do was no
longer the best deal we can do and so we
changed direction and that didn't go
over very well in China and it was right
and iron ore pricing was going through
the roof we were looking at ways of
changing the way iron ore was priced
from long-term contracts that where the
pricing was set annually to more of a
quarterly or a spot market price they
didn't like that then there was an
arrest of our people for something they
had been doing for some time though I
mean these things all damaged us quite
significantly to be honest with you in
China we have been working on that
relationship very hard and we've been
using some very renowned experts to help
us as well and we have made quite a bit
of progress but we still have work to do
but i would say we're very happy with
the progress we've made today there's
one up here
no it's the inability of supply to keep
up with demand so China and I in round
figures I should have a slightly more
precise but in round numbers they'll be
I think importing around 600 million
tons of iron ore this year if you go
back to when I was a CFO in the iron
iron ore group it was a hundred million
and if you would have told somebody that
someday not even 10 years from now but
someday they might be importing 500
million tons of iron ore they would have
just left you out of the room absolutely
laughed you out of the room and they're
doing it ten years later and so there's
been a massive under investment in
supply and there's a catch up but it's
still finding resources finding big
resources there's infrastructure issues
there's all the issues around
negotiating with governments for fiscal
stability I'll just use an example I'll
go from iron ore to copper because I was
intimately involved in our entry into
the Mongolian copper asset but it took
us about two years maybe two and a half
to negotiate an investment agreement
that would allow us to feel comfortable
investing five billion dollars in that
country but to put put that in
perspective if that mine was up and
running today that single operation
would represent twenty-five percent of
the GDP of the country so you can
understand why they were nervous they
were nervous that a western country was
company was going to take advantage of
them that they were going to negotiate a
bad deal that in hindsight three or four
years later if prices were much better
other things that we didn't look so good
and so and we were nervous of that as
well we this is an operation that will
last for 60 probably more but at least
60 years we don't want to make an
investment and start operating something
and find
four or five years later because of
issues that we have we lose it due to X
procreation so it's all these issues
that the governments are struggling with
as well that we struggle with and
there's a permitting process you can
imagine as i showed in the picture in
the first people people are going to
fight us on permitting they don't
necessarily want that in there being
done but they want their air
conditioning they want the
refrigerator's they want the cars they
want their houses they want their
apartments they want their ipads their
ipods and you know if you can't grow it
it usually comes from mining and so
whether we like that or not it's the
truth so we've got to do one or the
other and maybe you know over time the
the world will become where we grow more
things than then digging them out of the
earth but that that is that is going to
take a very long time to change that's
not those are not the things that happen
overnight people and that does vary from
place to place so in Australia where you
you see a lot of gap not only
commodities what gas is a commodity but
you see the energy but when I talk about
commodities I mean copper coal I don't
know those sorts of things there you
cannot get enough engineers to and just
people to do construction and run
operations is going to be a big deal in
other places like Africa or Mongolia we
have people but they're not and I don't
mean this rudely so they're not educated
and trained to do the work we're asking
them to do we just built a massive
operation very very similar to what i
said about Mongolia in Madagascar and a
couple of you know a billion dollars in
round terms port massive mining
operation for tio2 the people that we
had to hock that we try hired and
trained to work there to build it
two now operate it don't even wear shoes
and yet they can't come work on our
operations without hard hard toed you
know boots and safety gear and matrade
welders mechanics we can we train those
people to do that but it you know that
takes time to do and so that that's
another issue that we face in developing
worlds in developing countries sorry
that that is a major issue in the supply
chain it varies but things like just
like we cannot bring on enough supply of
copper iron ore are further down our
supply chain people that make trucks
shovels tires explosives those are all
things that I think over time that will
be bottlenecks and they'll expand at
different paces and some of those
bottlenecks might disappear for awhile
and they'll open up someplace else but
those kinds of things shipping could be
one as well it isn't right now but with
all that trade that's going on on the
water you can have times where you have
a lack of global shipping capacity
rizzoli is a BHP's oversee
30 and musician attempts and is under
the pressure in the press and I think
from Epsom shareholders do you find that
there's an inordinate pressure on films
like yourself and ESPN xstrata to
continue to grow grow grow and two by
two by five different companies rather
than just grow yeah that there is quite
a bit of pressure on us and it's kind of
funny we do get different pressures from
different shareholders and I'll come
back to that in a minute but there is a
pressure on us to grow partly due to our
customers because they don't want to
have the high prices that as high as
they're encountering a copper recently
it's falling back over the last few days
but went over four dollars a pound which
you know it's just iron ore prices as
you said are very high customers don't
like pain that and so there's pressure
there that pressure from our
shareholders to grow into these very
profitable pricing regimes that we face
right now some shareholders that are
more that are not necessarily company
Pickers but are so big that they have to
invest across the commodity space
sometimes we get pressure for them to
not invest too quickly because that
creates oversupply and drives prices
down and brings you know will bring
profits and valuations down for the for
the whole industry so we get that which
is kind of an anomaly as well but it's
getting harder to find really true tier
1 assets and they take a long time to
develop and that's one of the issues
that we're trying to get our hands
around we found a what we would refer to
as a Tier one diamond deposit in in
Canada and it's been an operation for
quite some time but from find to first
diamond was a decade and that's and it's
in it's getting worse fine to first
copper is now taking in places maybe 15
years and so it is becoming very hard to
find and develop and get in an operation
now for us we usually like to
a massive operation and that's one of
the issues we've been facing in Guinea
is we basically it's taking too much
time studying and figuring out how to
build it get the logistics in place to
build a 12 billion dollar operation they
want jobs today they don't want jobs in
a deck well you can imagine politicians
they don't care about jobs in a decade
they want jobs today and so how can we
go in and develop one or two million
tonne operation that costs six or seven
hundred million dollars it gets things
flowing today while we finish the
studies and then build something bigger
that that isn't in our DNA that it needs
to be and so we're looking at how we
have to change that buying companies our
shareholders our investors when I say
shareholders not just the mom and pump
in the street but kind of the city the
people from the city are very worried
that we'll pay too much and that's a big
concern so there's that constant
friction yeah I'm sorry if I'm not going
in order but so forgive night my
ignorance cuz i have not submit this
entry level but it whenever I think
about mining I find it to actually be
quite challenging because it seems like
a lot of the variables that you need to
deal with our independent of what your
company can actually deal with and it
sounds like there are a number of things
that you have to be very very good at
just from your talk strategic
forecasting but not five or ten year
cells like 50 years down the road
probably implementation I'm wondering
when you think about those the actions
that are within the control rio tinto
what are the areas that you think Rio
Tinto has a competitive advantage over
your competitors of where their areas
that you really can make a difference
and that's where you're driving value
above when your competitor goodra so we
think we think and around the way in
which we operate so that's both from
excellence in that we are efficient and
we run a very good operation that is a
safe operation and you see when when
there are issues you saw the recent
issuing in Chile where the miners were
trapped underground safety is a big
issue for our industry i would say that
our if i don't have a slide today but if
i was to put up a slide of how our
industry does against other industries
and then how we do within our industry
you would find that you'd be surprised
to find that the safety in our industry
is much better than a lot of industries
that you would you would expect and that
the way we perform within our industry
is one of the best but it is something
that we work on and work on and work on
we take it very seriously i I am very
comfortable in saying this is a true
value doesn't mean we're perfect doesn't
mean we get it all right doesn't mean
that people don't get hurt this year
we've had two fatalities within the
within Rio Tinto our goal is obviously
no fatalities ever but it's something
that we work very hard with we work very
hard on managing the impact on the
environment as I said in the first
picture we have an environmental impact
but managing that the best we can I
think we have a competitive advantage in
doing that we're working on biodiversity
we now have a stated goal of neutral
impact on on the on in biodiversity so
that when we go in and
we have to develop an operation we're
very careful about figuring out in
understanding the makeup of what animals
are there what plant life and what not
in that that we make make up for the
thing the impact that we have working
with communities and governments and
I've seen that in Mongolia so when we
went into Mongolian and is not a
resource we found somebody else found
and we had to be buy into it and then we
had to help negotiate the investment
agreement the government of Mongolia
would only sign that agreement with two
companies and we were one of those two
companies the other one was being they
would have with PHP they would have but
you know so as we went through that that
was a it was so became so clear to me
that was a competitive advantage for us
we're now working very hard at making
technology and innovation a technical
advantage and we have a few instances
where we've done very well what we we
run our train system in Australia
remotely driverless trains we're working
on driverless trucks we're working on
automated tunneling for underground
mines we're working on sorting system
sorting systems that are used in the
food industry but if we could bring them
into our industry we could open up
resources that are now on economic and
make them economic we're spending a lot
of money on innovation and I'll be
honest these mining companies have not
been ahead of the innovation curve I
think I think you
what came out it varies by commodity so
you can imagine in the diamonds mine
very not much with logistics you can we
basically carry it out in a suitcase we
try to make sure other people don't do
that that we do I actually went I was in
charge of our diamond operations I went
into our and they laid out on a table
that was about twice as wide but about
two hundred thousand carats of diamonds
in gold not much in the logistics but
when you think about bauxite with which
goes into is the first portion of making
aluminium takes a lot of bauxite to make
aluminium it's a logistic shipping it's
so it's mainly around rail and shipping
are the biggest logistic challenge
challenges that we face and when we find
deposits quite often they're not near
ports or they're not near rail
infrastructure and it used to be I when
I was in iron ore it used to cost a
million dollars a kilometer to build a
rail line I'm assuming now it's probably
at least two to two and a half million
dollars a kilometer so if you're a
thousand miles thousand kilometers away
from the port it's very expensive to
build a rail line and so you have to
build an operation that is so big enough
to support that major investment you
can't just build a small mind and
usually then if you sometimes we have to
build our own ports which are very
expensive as well coming back to the
China question one of the reasons were
were work trying to work with China is
because they can build infrastructure
like that including rail and port much
cheaper than we can so we're trying to
access that that capability come over
here
I will just curious about how you think
the joint ventures projects are going to
impact the competitor
um we we have a lot of joint ventures
and we entered them for different
reasons I think they will continue to be
a major aspect of our business we would
much rather in most instances own and
operate a hundred percent of our project
I think what you'll find now is that
going forward governments will want a
piece of that pie so there will be more
joint ventures that will include a piece
with the government in on our project in
Madagascar they got twenty percent in
Molech Mongolia they got a third they
wanted half they actually wanted
51-percent a third so you're seeing that
they see these as strategic resources
they want to be involved we may do it
too we may knew it because we need to
access somebody else's capabilities like
Chinese strengths and building
infrastructure and so they may need to
have a cut of the pie as well and part
of it is these projects are becoming so
big as a financial diversification as
well who a big project used to be five
hundred million dollars was an enormous
project in the mining space a decade ago
we're looking at developing a really
quite a tier what we refer to as a
first-class Tier one asset in Arizona
for a copper project will spend a
billion dollars on it before we decide
if we're going to build it and so when
you look at the kinds of investments
that we have to make as a company I mean
they're just enormous investments and so
joint ventures kind of play in that as
well but they introduced their own their
own problems as well I think here
I was wondering if commodities trading
both in terms of proprietary trading and
also risk management yeah it's it's
something I'll be honest with you that
we struggle with we have knowledge of
markets that other people that should be
better than other people that we should
be able to use to our advantage in
trading and we can also manage some of
the risks that we have around our
operations through trading we do we do
use trading for that and I think we do
that fairly well but we've always
struggled with with being more like a
Glencore if you're familiar with
glencore real traitor because first of
all we'd be competing against banks
financial institutions and we're not
sure we're best suited to compete
against them firstly because our
compensation systems are so different
and so can we hire the best and
brightest to do that and so will we
truly have a competitive advantage
against those those companies and groups
we kind of keep coming down that we
probably don't now Glencore actually
does do operations and trading they do
both and I know the CEO Glencore very
well and he talks that they have two
completely different compensation and
systems of managing people and they
don't seem to clash I'm not sure in our
company of having a group of 500 people
maybe the twenty percent of them all
made more than the CEO of the company
that causes problem I those are the
issues that we think that we struggle
with our core strengths are mining and
whether it's the operational excellent
excellence the environmentalist
assailable development dealing with
governments running operation and we've
tended to say those are strengths those
are core strengths will stay with those
as bisazza natural resource prevalence
huge social indeed of a genetical and in
its it's sort of the other lent a
blindness and we continue to test that
and I won't say that five years from now
we won't come to a different decision
we're at today but those are kind of
that that arguments that we go back and
forth and making those decisions
internally I think your projects are a
significant chunk of the gdp how do you
manage place price inflation rates as
your projects it's a very good question
so that Dutch disease issue what we did
when we went as we were working with the
government we help them go to places
like Chile Alaska Canada which I think
has managed their a resource country but
they suffer from it as well I mean you
see there what's happened to their
currency when I lived in Australia that
the Aussie dollar was worth fifty cents
to the US dollar it's a parody today so
they do get impacted by commodity
pricing and swings there's no doubt
about it but what we tried to do is take
them to places that have managed it well
and so that they can learn upfront
because they will suddenly get an influx
of money and let's be it's going to say
being politicians I don't care if you're
a Mongolian politician or a us
politician it doesn't really matter your
instinct is they're going to use it to
get reelected next time because they
have very short-term horizons and so we
we've tried to work with them to set up
schemes like Alaska has or Chile has
actually done a very good job where they
base their government spending spending
on what they consider a long-term price
of copper mooned coppers above that they
put it all into their you know rainy day
fund and when it's below it they're not
afraid to draw from it so that they help
manage that but it's still going to have
an impact
and and you just try and help work best
that you can that they can set up
mechanisms and institutions that help
manage it by Jackson countries like that
depend on the government's so the rate
of success in managing their currencies
are you tryna hide out no we we don't do
hedging other than in very specific
circumstances if we have a very large
capital spend over a short period of
time and when i say short over a year or
two or three we may hedge that large
capital spend so that we don't get
significant spikes but over long periods
we don't hedge our operations either
from commodity or currency our customer
our shareholders buy into our company
for commodity exposure to commodity
prices so we let them take that and from
a currency perspective our view is and
it it largely plays out is that
currencies are counter of commodity
price and so as prices come down
currencies become less valuable and our
costs go down in u.s. dollars and so
it's kind of an offset to lower
commodity prices our costs go down and
when prices are higher on costs go up
but margin wise we make a lot more money
I think right here
yeah about you are like prison Oh what
was in this such a big companies how was
that past and what do you find out the
biggest challenge yeah it's an
interesting question i did want to talk
about careers for a minute we're kind of
running out of time i guess i would say
from that perspective is as you enter
the workforce have an idea which may
evolve over time of what you would like
to do and where you want to go and
without being pushy and without being in
you know the moment you get a new job
don't start talking to your boss about
what the next job is do your job do a
good job but don't let it go forever I
believe it is very important and I as a
leader I think it's very important for
me my most important job is managing
people I will say something that is true
but probably not very popular I don't do
any work and people are in the
organization probably love to hear me
say that I do work through people that's
the only way I get where you know when
you get to a certain point it's usually
around in the u.s. system what I would
refer to as around that vice president
level in an organization everything you
do is through people so managing people
is very important so both sides of that
first the employee I have been not
aggressive but I regularly have through
my career had conversations with my boss
about how am i doing what am I expect
what are my expectations and you do they
meet your expectations i think i can do
X Y is going to say Zed I'll say Z do
you think I can do that and if not what
do I need to do to fill the gaps can I
work on projects can I do this and and
as long as the word I use is alignment
if if there's alignment in between you
and the organization's that's great
you're working in the right path if
there's not then you have to figure out
how you're going to fill those gaps and
and if your view of what you can do in
the organization's view is different and
you can't bridge that gap then you're
going to have to decide am i okay with
that and is that where I'll be and if
not then you may have to move someplace
else I mean I think those and I can use
a few experiences I mean when it when I
was in working in London for the first
time I was the head of our financial
planning analysis and I i had never I I
came to understand how important
understanding and working in Australia
was in our company and I just you know I
said I'd really like to work in
Australia I went and talked to my boss
about this book a month later he just so
happened a job opening on Australia
which was perfect for me i ended up
moving to australia about three months
later got that you know got that
experience which was very important I
had a very similar experience before
that my job before that way I'd only
been in the job for about a year I
talked to my boss I said listen I don't
want you to wonder if a job comes up is
he interested in going and working in
London I said I am if an opportunity
comes up in London I'm interested in it
I but I know I've only been in my job
for 14 months I'm not looking for today
I'm not kidding you within the month he
called me up and said there's a job in
London do you want to go and I went to
work in London until I think it's very
important that you do that I had a very
similar experience when I went from
being a CFO to a CEO of one of our
business operations where I had somebody
that mentored meeting and helped me the
other thing is from a leader so as you
become a leader one of the key things is
managing people and it's one of the
hardest things you'll do it's easy when
people are doing well because it's easy
to work with them to praise them to
reward them when they're doing well when
they're not doing well it's sucks it's
the hardest thing you'll have to do but
you have to do it and so you have to pee
treat people with respect you have to
treat them with dignity but you have to
work with them to try and turn them
around if they're not working out what
are the reasons what can we do to help
fix it sometimes that's successful
sometimes it's not
and when it's not successful I'm not
trying to sound like an ogre but when
it's not successful if you have people
that are not carrying their load on your
team it will only drag you down in the
rest of your team and you can't accept
it and it's one of the hardest things
you have to do as a leader you don't
want to do it you don't want to face up
to it so so as an employee put yourself
on the other side of that equation if
things aren't quite working out quite
often your leader won't tell you because
it's not any fun so that's why you you
you sometimes as a person have to make
sure you're keeping that dialogue open
and when I the more and more times that
I've heard CEOs of companies taught this
they come back to this point over and
over again they were too slow to make
decisions on people that were not
performing well and it's no fun and you
always treat people with dignity and
respect and you try and help them to do
better but sometimes it just is not a
good fit and you need to move on for
both people safe so that was I was going
to talk a little bit about more careers
but that was kind of a condensed
industry how do people fit is that how
do you develop people within the company
given the volatility in commodities and
a long term extended time between behind
the line um we're realizing and we're
starting to invest a lot more in our
people systems it's probably an area
that we haven't done the greatest job in
the past so we're developed we've been
spending over the last six or seven
years but even more so over the last
couple of years a lot more on training
mentoring coaching we're starting to
really do a lot more on diversity both
gender and if I diversity as well and
we've been working on gender diversity
now with some emphasis for about
five or six or seven years with some
real concerted effort and we're showing
some progress when you look at national
diversity where we're going in the
future we don't have those people
working in our company so if you think
we're going to go develop stuff in in
the Congo or in Guinea how many
Ghanaians do we have working in our off
very few and particularly at levels that
can engage with Prime Minister's
presidents and that language skills so
we're very heavily we speak if I can say
American australian and canadian now and
brit british english very heavy we're
starting to get more French because of
the Alcan acquisition we have very few
if you look at the scheme of things
people that are from South America nor
in our company and we've just made a
decision that we're going to have to go
out and hire a hundred indians and we're
going to have to bring them into our
operations and train them and hopefully
over time you know as we develop
operations in India we're doing the same
thing with Mongolia so we were just
we've just gone out we're doing
scholarship programs but we're hiring
people out of university and bringing
them to into our operations and getting
in training because when when we run an
operation in Mongolia we don't want it
run by a bunch of white British or
Americans be honestly we want to run by
Mongolians ultimately what happened day
one because they might not have the
skills but over time we want Mongolians
or Indians or Ghanaians took to run
those operations but we're a little bit
behind that but we're starting its money
money and effort
thank you picture